[Música]
gracias gente bonita
a nivel que ha ido subiendo pero
si vamos a arrancar preguntándoles
ustedes quién de aquí no ejercen estudio
algo y no lo haces
pero hacer una marca que yo
con orgullo yo no hago lo que estudie
algunas manos veo que ya cambio su plan
de vida saben que pensaban que a esta
altura ya van a tener niños casa
patinetas voladoras y ahorita
nada de eso
varios de otras manos ok ok gracias
gracias gracias
lo digo porque hoy justo quiero hablar
acerca de esto cambio
lo que nosotros planeamos y lo que pasó
puede ser divertido
en mi caso radical
y llegué a méxico un niño colombiano a
un nombre y pues ahora soy mujer
mexicana
que me dijeron para cantar rancheras
bien
no es queja yo vivo de quién soy yo vivo
de mi imagen vivo de presentar el
público de estar en escenario soy
comediante
y más bien
me gusta mucho analizar el por qué soy
quien soy y es que en últimas a muchas
personas le ha llamado la atención de mi
existencia
tengo un raro galardón en casa
es un premio que como dice y premio a la
mujer de calidad
por los materiales
el punto es que si yo me hubiera dicho a
mí hace 10 años esta va a ser tu vida
hoy
y entró en un pequeño pánico saben es
decir los del caballero en diez años
usted va a ser una comediante mujer
perdón
y de nuevo no es queja porque como les
digo que yo estudié física y ahora estoy
en comedia
bien raro hubiera sido arrancar en
comedia y acabar en física
oye sabes quién está llevando ciencias
nucleares de la unam way ricardo famila
[Aplausos]
muchas personas de hecho tengo una
cantidad de premios menciones de estoy
en una lista que se llama las veces 100
las tops y en mujeres según la bbc
solo hay dos mujeres mexicanas
james bond y yo
sólo hay una mujer colombiana yo
también estoy lista por forme una lista
que se llama tops y en mujeres más
poderosas de méxico que es raro porque
en casa no me dejan pedir pizza con piña
pero además es saber soy mujer trans y
colombiana que hago en esa lista
entonces he visto cosas muy raras y les
quiero compartir un poco de lo que yo he
aprendido el cómo me enfrento con esto y
ojalá ojalá ustedes top en el como
llevarse esto para sus vidas porque esto
es histérico es una locura el pensar que
diez años ustedes van a hacer
comediantes presentando en un cambio de
género consideren lo
el cuento es que yo aprendí a improvisar
bien cuando se presentan estas cosas
sale alguien a decir a huevos rape as
ya quisiera
yo hago una práctica de la impro en
particular que algunos pueden conocer
otros puede que piensen que así es y
otros saben o lo han hecho que simple o
teatral
yo aprendí a subir un escenario sin
saber de qué hablar sin haber preparado
nada
a improvisar
nada que ver con hoy pero bueno
el cuento es que para hacer este tipo de
cosas
te subes al escenario y das una hora de
teatro sin saber cuál es el guión cómo
le haces no improvisar tiene su técnica
sus modos y el por qué yo vivo como vivo
es porque haciendo esto en contra algo
muy bonito
y esque
no sólo sucede en el escenario que las
cosas se van a la chingada perdón
es en la vida todos ustedes que
levantaron la mano con el cambio de
planes o que ya no ejercen es
técnicamente ya están improvisando la
vida es una improvisación
en ningún momento están ustedes pensando
uno hoy pues estos son los planes del
día y que se ejecuten a cabalidad
entonces hay un par de cosas que
aprendes para hacer esta impro teatral
que quiero que tenga presentes
digo sepan ustedes que la impro justa es
un proceso es algo que está con ustedes
y que lo podrán aplicar en algún espacio
entonces llévense lo adonde crean que
encaje
acto seguido mañana improvisando en la
calle
miren es que luego cuando hablo justo de
esto comienza con es que eres muy
abstracta ofelia
les doy un ejemplo
hace muchos ayer es estuve grado de una
serie en guadalajara y cuando llegué
allá me dijeron bienvenida al silicon
valley de latinoamérica
porque no era colombia bogotá porque eso
dicen allá
pero luego una vez estuvo en santiago de
chile y no aquí es el silicon valley de
la web
y seguro aquí en cuernavaca alguien
tiene su silicon valley des no me
explico
el tema es que hay una cantidad ridícula
de lugares que quieren ser silicon
valley no los culpo y lo que hacen es
que entonces reunir a muchas empresas
les ponen una cosa que se llama close te
dicen de sense
un día hablé con una persona super
importante para el tema de lo que es el
silicon valley el se llama sam alma él
es el director y creo que fundador de
una empresa que fondea emprendimientos
nuevos cosas como el bien vi dropbox
uber redit y podría hablar toda la tx
solo de esto pero le pregunté a él qué
piensas tú de que todo el mundo quiere
tener su silicon valley y que ya hay un
silicon valley él me dice bueno el
silicon valley está donde está uno por
el clima
y dos porque la gente en san francisco
vive habla y como la con la diversidad
él me dice la gente escudier yo como
mujer trans gay me últiles que
él me dice que cuando vives en la
diversidad y aceptas que las cosas no
tienen nada que ver con lo que lo
planeaste siempre estás improvisando y
entonces traes una mentalidad de buscar
cómo ajustar para que las cosas
funcionan entiéndase algunos tales algún
día quería emprender y digo todo
emocionada decirle a sus amigos tengo
una idea espectacular vas a una
panadería de barrio que a poner acá
abajo
lo primero que leones y sus amigos es
toda una lista negra de cómo no va a
funcionar no ya hay una en la ciudad de
méxico barrio con el barrio cómo se te
ocurre te van a saltar no ves es hay
tantas cosas rotas con tu emprendimiento
y entonces te que así es ok
en el silicon valley como lo hice
en vez de pensar todos los modos en los
que va a fallar la gente se sienta a
pensar en que hay que cambiar para que
funcione
todos conocen esta historia espero
[Aplausos]
se va a poner triste
por qué
en esta película que para los que no
saben nos presentan un emprendimiento
imposible que hacemos las con salones
vip
no si llevamos gasolina a la gente en
sus lugares de trabajo
y nos reímos a madres y claro como las
gasolineras no está idea no sé qué
y mientras estamos acá pensando en todos
los modos en los que no funcionan en el
silicon valley
pum
esto es la intro esto es pensar que las
cosas no van a salir como lo planeado ya
ver cómo lo hacemos para que sí
otro ejemplo más rápido pero también
sirve para el amor no les voy a dar
consejos directos acá no se preocupen
pero si les puede decir algo cuantos
dilemas de amor se han solucionado
cuando una de las personas en la pareja
que está teniendo problemas acepta que
tiene una bestia dentro con gustos y
deseos y con cosas raras que hay que
aceptar saber no me quiero meter en
específicos pero
entienden
la impro es parte de la vida para tantas
cosas
pero lo importante es aceptar que nada
es perfecto de hecho mientras más
imperfecto sea mejor
entonces antes de que digamos en saber
ofelia ok llegas que la experta del
escenario
les explico tres reglas simples de la
impro para que se lleven a su corazón y
ojalá les sirva
porque es la guía de ministerial
diges en una tv x
regla número uno se nos olvidó jugar
cuando fue la última vez que alguien fue
a su casa golpeó hoy pueden salir a
jugar armando
todos los que no se llaman arman desde
pues nunca ofelia
me entienden y es más déjense de que
alguien llega a golpear que de hecho
ustedes salieron a jugar no esto puede
pasar en línea esto puede pasar en los
juegos que pueden ser vamos a un juego
de mesa nunca se reúnen hace sentido y
en la vida también en el espacio laboral
por ejemplo jugar es moverse dentro de
un set de reglas con gozo porque se
puede
no debería se pruebe sigo entre la regla
jugamos puede ser hasta divertido si
usted es en su espacio laboral están
solo ejecutando no es que tenemos la
metodología espectacular el sistema el
proceso
el rol
si ustedes están haciendo eso no se
sorprendan si su trabajo es automatizado
porque las confundo juegan
pero porque además hay gozo en el juego
ahí es cuando se descubre ahí es cuando
se empapan ustedes de ideas nos dan un
manto se puede ser así y se nos fue hay
gente que está más preocupada y esto es
una lección que me dio una persona que
traigo muy bien el corazón cliente que
está muy preocupada porque su rol de
jefe se vea bien más que por ser buena
jefe conocemos pícaras y caras picadas
claro
si tienes al corazón que se nos ha
olvidado jugar como niños
y no hay problema luego segunda regla de
la impro también se nos olvidó escuchar
y cuando digo escuchar es las mejores
conversaciones se manejan como el jazz
no bueno ya ofelia bájale
cuando nosotros ya sabemos que vamos a
decir realmente no estamos escuchando
solo estamos dejando que esa persona
ejecute sus ideas para luego yo decir lo
mismo
escuchar es tener la disposición de
cambiar
dejar que diga todo lo que tengo que
decir luego pensar eso no es así me la
pongo yo
entonces para rematar no nos estamos
comunicando sino también estamos
ejecutando este acto de ritual de solo
conversar con nosotros mismos formando
la otra persona
si no me creen
cuando haga una llamada en skype piense
en cuánta gente está
yo abro skype mi compañero abre skype y
nos estamos viendo analiza nadie
nuestras cámaras
qué nos pasa no nos escuchamos y la
regla más importante de todas es decirle
que sí a las propuestas de la vida
y el cuento es que estamos muy
acostumbrados a decir que no
porque tenemos miedo porque evadir es
muy fácil el si es liberador es súper
poderoso
voy a hacer un pequeño experimento
quiero que me digan que si a todo lo que
diga
en voz alta ok se les va gracias quieren
que les cuente una historia
ok y quieren que esa historia se trate
acerca de una mujer emprendedora
y que esa mujer emprendedora descubre
que en su oficina a lo mejor tiene que
conquistar espacios para que luego ya
llegue y con su magia le enseña nosotros
lo que es una mujer cool
y en lo que hace esto de repente
aparecen niñas chiquitas que se unen con
ella y se unen a su historia se van a
pelear contra todos los males
la divertida historia
hagamos el mismo ejercicio pero ahora
les puede decir
díganme que no
está listos
quieren que les cuento una historia
aunque gracias a esa felicidad
y como uno arruina tantas cosas no
siempre decimos no de frente solo lo
pasamos a luego de repente quizás pero
pero hay mil modos de decir que no
puedes tener una cadena de 17 si uno se
acabó
ahora en la impro en el escenario
mucha gente
comienza a aventar propuestas y pues el
clima pues algo que vi pues es algo que
yo mi compañero pero en la vida también
de repente llega alguien y si tengo una
idea para cómo arreglar este proceso en
el trabajo o quiero hacer esto con
nuestra relación
si le decimos que sí a todo nos puede
meter en problemas así
entonces en el próximo sí
esto es sumamente poderoso de hecho lo
tengo tatuado
porque el xii es le digo que si a tu
propuesta pero yo añado algo no es un
contestatario
es lo digo que sí a lo tuyo por loquito
que suene pero no te digo que si a lo
tuyo por loquito que suene y yo añadió
el perro es una forma de signo
entonces
sumando todo esto el si al escuchar el
jugar se pueden divertir mucho con esta
impro para su vida cuando alguien me
quiere insultar en la calle o en twitter
o en algún espacio lo primero que me
dicen es pareces hombre
entonces a la policía del género yo
siempre les digo sí
y qué bonito poder ser hombre así
no entienden por qué esperan que les
digas que no y eso es un ejemplo
chiquito puede ser algo que no pueden
hacer ustedes que influye en su trabajo
puede ser algo que no pueden hacer
ustedes que fluyen su familia desde que
yo aplicó esto puede hablar con muchas
personas de movus cantando podía porque
si sumamos todo eso entonces ahora sí
puedo llegar a lo que les viene a decir
es que se tienen que dejar caer
ojo no les estoy diciendo que fallen
no que no más por dejarlo en dicho
fracasar no los hacen fracasados
ok
pero no les estoy diciendo frases sino
su vista ahora la empresa debe saber que
está
para aprenderlo
déjense caer déjense golpear fracasar
soltar y experimentar qué pasa de bajada
capaces de bajar descubren qué es lo que
me interesaba era esto estoy aquello
a ese sentido el tema no es caer es
dejarse caer
porque entonces ahí hay juego y escucha
y hay cosas que no han vivido y a lo
mejor ahí pueden explorar algo que ojalá
y les desbloquee algo más
porque de no haber sido por adoptar
estas reglas yo nunca hubiera podido
subir un escenario a hacer las bobadas
que hago cada going pro
pero tampoco habría podido estar ningún
lugar donde podría quizás dirigir o
apoyar movimientos
si ustedes creen que dirigir un equipo
es cuestión de tenerlo todo planeado les
tengo una noticia
todo hay que improvisar lo
si ustedes se dejan caer y se dejan
gozar y se dejan jugar a lo mejor se
topa con que adentro de ustedes hay algo
más que no están viendo porque están
preocupados por no caer
entonces en últimas
en escuchar en un lugar decir que sí y
en añadirle algo de usted es capaz y se
topan con qué
igual y no era una científica sino una
comediante que estaba dentro
contando chistes
para la vida
muchas gracias